that's what i'm saying like  it is blatant hollywood [ __ ] yeah can  you imagine  the number one gangster  rapper in the whole world  used to pat [ __ ] down and tell  them to spread their cheeks  and lift their feet up and check then oh  i heard about them you know what i'm  gonna rap let me get his name he's not  getting out right all right let me get  his [ __ ] that's exactly what happened  yeah i can't ever listen to any song of  that man again my last two years a  million dollars every day and  some days as much as three million  dollars you know it was worth going to  prison for is what you're thinking would  you mind no it wasn't worth it no i  wouldn't i wouldn't do it over never  trade it back no no it wasn't worth  money it's not worth 20 years ago  no time where the police said you gained  permission  john if i would have gained permission i  had a thousand kilos  [Laughter]  so you think i would have said it's okay  to search my trunk  you